oh hello there
I'm Abby sharp welcome to a special
edition of Abby's kitchen called toilet
talk where I uncover your deepest
darkest poopy ASET the record straight
[Music]
now our question from today comes from
Georgina Dear Abby I notice I've got
some serious gas and bloating every time
I eat all I favor carb loaded foods my
girlfriends say I must be gluten
intolerant but I read on Facebook that
that's BS is gluten intolerance a real
condition or is it all in my head find
gluten confused at Georgina okay
Georgina let me break it down for you
because this is a sensitive topic so
gluten intolerance or non-celiac gluten
sensitivity is defined as the presence
of gastrointestinal IBS like symptoms in
the absence of celiac disease that seems
to improve on a gluten-free diet so the
only way to test for gluten intolerance
is to rule out celiac disease and a
wheat allergy and to do a food
elimination test so it's basically a
diagnosis of exclusion so this of course
has led a lot of researchers out there
to question the legitimacy of gluten
intolerance so let's take a look at
other research dollars so so very early
biomarker studies were able to identify
some abnormalities in the antibody
levels of people who self-identified as
being gluten intolerant and this hinted
towards some kind of sort of systemic
immune activation that was different
from people who have celiac disease this
was sparked a whole bunch of dietary
challenge study so in the early studies
it was found that when people were put
on a gluten-free diet when they
self-identify becoming gluten intolerant
in some cases they started to feel a
little bit better the problem with some
of these early studies is that other
components of wheat based products like
thought for example which we've talked
about in that depth in this video right
here we're not isolated or accounted for
also a lot of the participants didn't
exactly have alias disease ruled out
they may have had the biopsy done at
some point but a lot of them are already
on a gluten
diet which can interfere with the test
result subsequent research by a leading
research team in the field was able to
better isolate things like spod map away
from gluten their first small study
found that those who had gluten
intolerance who are given a small amount
of gluten reported slightly more
gastrointestinal symptoms than those who
are not given gluten
however not everyone who had gluten
intolerance reported symptoms on gluten
in their follow a trial may not only
remove thoughts after an equation but
they also remove things like dairy and
food chemicals as well and only two
people had any kind of symptoms for
latex gluten in other words they weren't
able to find a strong cause-and-effect
relationship between the consumption of
gluten and digestive issues in people
who did not have celiac disease so why
do you feel better when you go
gluten-free well there may be some
factors at play here first of all you're
probably going to be cutting out a lot
of overly processed foods when you cut
back on gluten you're also
simultaneously usually cutting back on
things like additives sugars and
saturated fat I mean if you've suddenly
stopped eating muffins and donuts all
day for breakfast you're probably going
to feel better but if you were to swap
at your regular donut breakfast for you
know an all-day gluten-free doughnut
vendor are you going to feel any better
Oh some of you may be a little bit but
for the most you guys out there probably
not so much next let's talk about sod
now so again you can watch an entire
video about FODMAPs right here but to
recap this stance for fermentable
oligosaccharides disaccharides
monosaccharides and polyols and
basically they're just carbs that are
found in a lot of different kinds of
grain products research suggests that
they may cause some digestive issues to
some people so they may actually be the
more likely culprits and lastly maybe
it's a wheat allergy well yes
you know most wheat products would be
cut out and eliminated on a gluten-free
diet however knowing that you had a
wheat allergy rather than gluten
tolerance would allow you to enjoy so
many more amazingly delicious nourishing
food things like oats spelt and barley
so why not just play it safe and kind of
gluten all to get
makes you feel better well if the
placebo or nocebo effect is at play you
could be doing more harm than good for
your health how I'll tell you why so
first of all you may be missing out on
some key nutrients grades are fantastic
sources of fibers antioxidants and B
vitamins without proper counseling or
even a legit reason you may be missing
out on some of these benefits number two
gluten-free foods may actually be worse
for you gluten-free breads and pastries
are not necessarily any more healthy
than their gluten filled counterparts in
fact oftentimes they've got less fiber
less protein fewer beneficial nutrients
and more sugar salt and fat in there to
make up for what's being taken out if
you're choosing gluten-free foods to
lose weight you definitely want to
actually compare the labels of products
to choose the food that best fits your
hold
finally shift to gut bacteria so agrees
are one of the best sources of the
beneficial prebiotic fibers so
eliminating greens and those fibers may
cause some shifts in your gut microflora
which may increase the risk of chronic
disease so bottom line the jury is still
out whether or not gluten sensitivity is
a real thing first thing I think we need
way larger studies with larger sample
sizes in order to make a definitive
statement on that however from my
perspective as a dietitian my opinion is
that yes there probably is such thing as
gluten intolerance it may actually be a
whole class of different conditions I
also think that likely a lot of the
relief that some people get from going
gluten-free is actually associated with
other non gluten components of these
kind of foods so if you are thinking
that maybe you have a subsidy to gluten
or anything else in food always speak to
your doctor or registered dietitian
first to get a proper diagnosis before
you go changing your diet
alright guys I hope you enjoyed this
video if you did be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below with
some of your burning toilet-table
questions subscribe to the channel and
I'll see you next time on Abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]